Napoleon Dynamite is the kind of movie
that rewards repeat viewings thanks to
some very subtle jokes and hints there
are plenty of odd details you just can't
catch the first time around because
you're too distracted by all of the
other odd details here are a few when we
first meet Kipp it doesn't seem like
he's particularly honest about how he
spends his time the point
don't be jealous that I've been Chyna
online with babes all day in fact Kipp
notes that it's one babe in particular
who he spends hours talking to late in
the film we finally meet hips lady love
laFonda who arrives on a bus and quickly
becomes an inseparable part of Kipps
life Kip and laFonda are clearly
different in just about every way but
they're able to start a relationship
surprisingly well it's actually quite
touching on some level but since Kip was
also bragging to Napoleon about another
lie besides we both know I'm training to
become a cage fighter since weight tip
you have the worst reflexes of all time
try and me Napoleon we're left to wonder
what exactly did Kip telefon de about
himself to get her interested in the
first place from the moment we first see
uncle Rico it becomes clear that he's an
unusual man he spends a lot of his
downtime throwing footballs and
recording himself doing quarterback
moves on his camcorder Rico is a man
pining for the glory days when he was a
high school star with prospects but it
turns out his particular delusions of
grandeur sometimes reach dangerous
heights how much you want to make a bet
I can throw a football over the
mountains yeah uncle Rico is desperate
enough to believe that he could purchase
a device that will allow him to travel
through time it's alarming that this
delusional man has been placed in charge
of two young relatives one of whom is
still in high school he might have the
best intentions and he might have some
profound sadness in his life but uncle
Rico is frightening lis out of touch
with reality speaking of the time
machine we get to see it in action when
Napoleon discovers it laying out on the
dining room table and ops to give it a
try
after reading the instructions Napoleon
has KITT plugged the device in
immediately and violently electrocuted
until his brother pulls the plug what
makes the scene a little disturbing
actually comes at the moment when Kip
lets a smile cross his face as Napoleon
rides in paint siblings will fight and
we've all been guilty of laughing just a
little too much when a friend or
relative was injured in some minor way
but Kip's smile here feels slightly
creepy did he know the time machine
wouldn't really hurt Napoleon that much
that he'd just not care is he slightly
sociopathic we'll never know
Pedro's a character who stands out in
the landscape of Napoleon's high school
this is part of what draws napoleon to
him but it also creates a strange
relationship between pedro and other
adults and students at the school it
reaches its apex late in the film when
summer is giving her student body
president speech who wants to eat
chimichangas next year not me
see with me it will be summer all year
though it's an obvious reference to
Pedro's Mexican heritage and it's part
of a pattern of casual racism that
lingers at various points in the film be
nicer to Pedro people the film's most
famous scene occurs during the student
body presidents assembly Pedro in need
of a skit to support his candidacy is
ready to give up but then Napoleon shows
off his sweet dance moves to the tune of
Jamiroquai's can defeat it's a classic
moment of mm cinema and it's largely
thanks to laFonda who upon learning
napoleon is interested in dance tosses
him an unmarked cassette and tells him
that her cousin made it now that could
just be a mixtape that her cousin made
but were given no label to tell us that
so keeping in mind that this is a
stretch isla fondest cousin Jamiroquai
uncle Rico is a man with many flaws he's
constantly looking to the past he's a
bully to Napoleon he enlists Kip as a
pawn in his schemes and he also happens
to be a bit of an egotistical lighter as
the film goes on though his sleazier
side sometimes takes a turn toward the
full-blown creepy
yes his delusions often make him into a
buffoon but consider various incidents
in the film that escalate nearer to the
end he tries to get Trisha and summer to
try his breast enhancement scheme then
corners dab at her photo studio
tells her to call him uncle Rico and
passes her a brochure well line that it
was Napoleon's idea then of course
there's the moment with Rex's wife
Starla I don't feel comfortable reading
this that's fine that's fine but do you
feel comfortable with me
finally the post-credits scene puts the
icing on the creepy cake when he sniffs
Lafond his garter after catching it at
the wedding it's played for laughs but
it's also pretty unnerving early in the
film Napoleon helps to establish his
particular brand of awkwardness by
telling Pedro that he doesn't have any
skills lamenting that he's not a martial
arts master or computer hacker though he
is able to draw a little but as the
story unfolds Napoleon just keeps
proving himself wrong at the FFA
competition he's able to analyze milk
correctly with almost no hesitation he's
able to learn the dance that wins the
election for Pedro in a matter of days
simply by practicing diligently then he
reveals his fishing skills the cacio
delicious bass and in the post-credits
scene he's tamed the horse Kip and
laFonda are supposed to ride away on
it's a heartwarming ending the film
proves that Napoleon does indeed have
skills he just has to go on a journey to
realize what they are check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you